- We all wanna go to
the gym and get swole.
But how many of us have
had accidents in the gym?
I'm about to diagnose them.
Running, running, running.
Oh!
That was a slide tackle.
Red card!
Just, ah, that's part of the exercise.
You gotta escape the thing.
You gotta do a quick
counter movement jump.
Bench, bench, bench, strong bench.
Oh, can't get it up.
I say, if you're alone in the gym
it's better to not use clips.
So that in a situation like this
you can throw the weight off to the side.
Obviously you gotta be ready
'cause it's gonna flick
to the other side as well.
See what's gonna happen here.
Oh, don't choke yourself out.
Yeah, this is a really big problem
'cause you could start putting pressure
on your veins here,
and actually cut off your
circulation to your brain.
But putting pressure on the
veins is a little bit easier
because they're thin walled.
So you start building up
pressure in your brain
and that can make you pass out on its own.
Wow, so, so dangerous here.
I hope he's safe.
(man chattering)
Okay, what's about to happen?
Is he gonna glide over the water?
Glide over the water.
Glide over the water!
Oh!
Honestly, those rapid kind
of changes of direction,
terrible on your joints.
Like the knee.
I just felt the ACL scream.
Like the person screamed,
but that person was merely
speaking for the ACL.
Uh!
Okay, parkour, parkour-
Ooh!
Oh, I wasn't ready for that.
Oh my God.
He's gonna have to visit a
dentist, a nasal surgeon.
He's not gonna breathe well.
He's probably gonna have to
drink smoothies for a while.
Ow!
I felt that.
No real injury.
But pain? Yeah.
Oh, what is happening here?
Honestly, like I've seen
weird stuff at the gym before.
Like people just misusing equipment.
But I've never seen stuff like this.
My hamstring is literally
jealous of her flexibility.
Okay, more people misusing machines.
Interesting.
That gentleman was very
much interested in her form.
Whoa!
That is a lot.
A lot of lumbar-sacral flexibility.
Whoa, that is...
He's a contortionist.
Okay.
Oh, cirque du soleil.
Okay, so that makes sense.
There's blood vessels called
the vertebral arteries
that run up and down
either end of your spine.
You're gonna put a lot
of pressure on those
by being in that hyper-extended position.
I wonder like, is he
cutting off circulation
to his lower extremities right now?
- [TikTok] I was just doing leg press
and watch what happened.
- What happened?
- [TikTok] I now have pinkeye.
- Okay, not how you get pinkeye.
Pinkeye is usually a viral condition,
sometimes bacterial.
Why did she have to come up like this?
I hope they know each other.
'Cause if they don't,
this is an awkward way to
get to know one another.
It's like, well hello crotch.
Shoulder circles.
Oh, front facing squat.
Oh, ooh.
There's a lot of strength
involved in that.
A lot of strength
(men groaning)
Medically that looked tangled.
- [TikTok] When you
accidentally get too hyped
for the homies PR.
- To me, if you did that to my back,
I would just cough.
Maybe 'cause I'm elderly now.
Dunk!
(woman laughing)
Oh! Double fail! Double fail.
(upbeat music)
Okay, we got...
Oh! Oh!
That is so dangerous.
That is why those machines have
to be secured to the ground.
Especially if you're
using resistance bands.
Because imagine if it hit
him in the back of the head,
knocked him unconscious,
then he fell with it.
Man, that could have been deadly.
Oh wow, he's struggling with that.
He's struggling. Whoa.
Oh, he's getting really red.
This is raising the intracranial pressure.
(Windows music)
Oh, shut down.
You know what could happen here?
He could have a vasovagal response
where he actually beared down too hard,
dilated all his blood vessels in his legs.
Therefore dropping the blood pressure,
not getting enough circulation
to his brain, and then.
That's why when he went down
he started feeling better.
'Cause then it was easier for the heart
to circulate that blood
from the lower extremities.
Whoa, throw up, jerk, ohp.
Oh! Went too far back.
I love that this guy
completely didn't care.
He was just like, oh yeah, you're good.
Rub some dirt in it.
(weights jingle)
Oh.
Oh, he knocked himself out.
Oh, Idubbbz.
Idubbz May 14th.
The chin, worst place to get hit
'cause you get the maximal rotation
and movement of the
brain inside the skull.
'Cause remember the brain sits in a soup.
So when he gets shaken like that,
you could easily get knocked out.
No excuses.
Oh, one legged.
Let's go.
Deadlifting, yeah.
Look at that hamstring activation.
That rear chain, posterior chain.
Good stuff, fella.
Ooh, what?
Is this real?
First of all, the balance
on this is incredible.
To dip with that much weight on you.
I mean, what is it, 315?
His triceps and shoulders, my God.
I wouldn't recommend that.
Oh my God.
Look at these tires.
I'm sorry.
I have worked out before,
but I have no idea what the
preset weights for tires are.
So that could be literally like 50 pounds
or it could be 5,000 pounds.
I don't know.
Does it mean this person can lift a semi?
Imagine their name is Axel. (laughs)
Oh!
Medial ankle injury like that?
Bone?
Oh my God.
You get struck on the bone on one side,
that could potentially be
a fracture or bone bruise.
But then you also evert your ankle,
therefore putting strain on
the anterior talofibular.
Anterior talofibular.
Anterior thabya Libya.
And then he fell onto the assault bike.
- [TikTok] 10 month bulk update.
My son's bulk is going really well.
But we tried to introduce ball sports
and he got a bit confused.
He does the occasional
assisted squat, which he loves.
So I did some tinkering in the garage
with a bunch of scraps
and built him a fully custom
quarter size leg press.
- That's so cute.
- [TikTok] He loves it
and he's gonna have some
monster quads and glutes soon.
- That's adorable.
Please don't make the baby over lift.
But that was really cute.
Hope the baby doesn't
get a splinter either.
This guy's really looking
thin on those legs.
Maybe that's the form is just absolutely.
What is going on?
Is he dancing?
Is this Zumba?
Zumba squats?
What is happening here?
This is what happens when
you load up the thing
to look cool for your girl.
You really have no idea what you're doing.
Okay, this is a cat with
toilet paper. Just chilling.
I would've done this better.
I would've thrown a toilet
paper on the tail as well.
And watched it move. (meows)
What did I just watch?
Whoa, that's savage.
How does he know?
God, if that hits,
tooth gone.
Okay, ship sliding off.
Very aesthetically pleasing.
Oh, not aesthetically pleasing.
Oh, nope, still aesthetically pleasing.
(instrumental music)
Oh, I know something's
gonna go wrong here.
He's with the ab wheel
and he's on the dumbbell.
And those aren't stable dumbbells.
They're not heavy enough to be stable.
Oh! Fractured tooth.
Fractured tooth, dislodged
tooth, fractured jaw.
Oh, just terrible.
Why would you do that?
For the gram.
He did it for the...
Oh, plyo.
Wow, balance and plyo.
Wow, he can do three?
Wow, that's really, really impressive.
Like, you guys have no
idea how hard that is.
(children cheer)
Props bro.
Okay, what do we got here?
Lots of plates.
The bar's bending, so you
know it's really heavy.
Okay. Good form.
Is the bar about to break?
Drop it bro.
Drop it!
(metals clatter)
Wow, that is a bad barbell.
That's really bad.
This gentleman's strong.
He got lucky there.
(man groans)
(metals clatter)
Whoa!
That is so dangerous.
God, that thing could
cut the other guy's face.
Lacerations, terrible.
(hip hop music)
Whoa!
Okay, that's gotta be a skit.
That's gotta be a skit.
That is way too evil.
You could really hurt yourself like that.
(fists whooshing)
Whoa, whoa!
Quick hands.
Quick feet.
She's in socks.
She was quick.
Yo, you've seen me box.
I'm not as good as that.
The stiff arm.
Niners. Niners.
Oh!
Wow.
Look at that.
Cowbell.
More cowbell please.
- I gotta have more cowbell.
- Oh, it's a bear.
Hey bear.
You gonna throw bear a little nugget?
(gentle music)
Wow!
That's a good bear.
(metal knocking)
Oh, they're using sound to guide the hoop.
Boom!
With the backboard.
Banks open on Tuesday, folks.
- [Cameraman] Banks
open on Tuesdays, folks.
(tone beeps)
- How many monsters I drink in a week,
because apparently I drink too much.
Monday.
Whoa.
Five in a day?
This is way too much.
Way too much.
I predict kidney stones,
and or kidney problems,
as the first sign...
Maybe inflammatory enzymes
of the liver going up.
(man chatters)
What do you, what do you?
Let go, let go.
That's a friction burn in a place
I don't want a friction burn.
(gentle music)
Ooh, you got clipped right in the face.
I'm not a huge fan of pressing down
on your heels and lifting
your butt off of the bench.
Some people say that this allows them
to target the lower portion of the chest.
I think that if you want to
do that, do a decline bench.
And the fact that he's
wearing those wrist supporters
at such a lightweight
tells me that he's
probably benching too much.
You can't allow one part of your body
to become overdeveloped
and think that everything
is gonna be okay.
You are bound to have an injury.
If your wrists are not strong
enough to hold the weight
and you have to put
something artificially here.
This is not, I'm not talking
about like strong men
or like these extreme weights.
As an average lifter,
it means you best be
working on those wrists
instead of using that.
And lower the weight a little.
What's harder, med school or law school?
We debate it right here
with the LegalEagle.
Click here to check that out.
As always, stay happy
and healthy in the gym.
(man grunts)
(upbeat music)